i've been playing by the rules way too
long
this is it's getting to a point of
ridiculousness that i'm somehow
responsible for the whole world around
me and i'm simply not and i'm unwilling
to be
we need to bend the curve california
governor gavin newsom has imposed some
of the most stringent covenanting
restrictions in america
and some golden state residents are
starting to revolt the dictatorial
attitude toward california residents
while dining in luxury traveling keeping
his business open
and sending his kids to in-person
private schools
is very telling about his attitude
toward california residents
and it is extremely hypocritical these
closures and stay-at-home orders
are flat-out ridiculous riverside county
sheriff chad bianco released this video
announcing that his department wouldn't
be enforcing the governor's order
sheriffs in los angeles county el dorado
county orange county and even the
governor's home of sacramento county
have also said they will not enforce
aspects of the lockdown order
bianco says county sheriffs are acting
within their legal authority
we're constitutional officers some of
the sheriffs believe that it's a
constitutional violation we don't answer
to a board of supervisors we don't
answer to
a governor or to a city council
we answer to the entire two and a half
million people of our county
do you worry that there is any sort of
legal action that can be
taken against the department for not
no they're doing a governor's orders
there's not
we don't have to arrest just because
there is a law on december 3rd
newsome stay-at-home order barred
in-person dining of any kind at
restaurants where hospital icu capacity
has fallen below
15 percent as it has in four of five
california regions
but there's no evidence that the
shutdown has stemmed the growth in cases
hospital admissions or fatalities
several restaurants in riverside county
are defying the ban
including marla's cocina and cantina in
the city of beaumont
at this point with this shutdown we
really have just kind of decided listen
i don't know how much more we can bend
you don't like it
don't come the cantina started only
accepting takeout orders for one week
in march the owner diego rose says never
again
i can't open up for just a ghost i would
be losing every day
at that point you have to make a
decision do you shut your doors
and lose all your inventory and let your
staff go
in hopes that somebody along the way
knew what they were talking about
and that two-week flat in the curve
thing was
what they said california's order to
stop outdoor diving has generated
outrage controversy and legal challenges
a county judge invalidated the la ban
on the ground that there's a lack of
scientific evidence to justify it
rose is even permitting his customers to
dine inside
though he's spaced out the tables and
installed extra ventilation
he also spent about 35 thousand dollars
converting an indoor space into an
open-air patio and keeps the restaurant
doors open whenever possible
we have every option your little heart
could desire you want to sit outside sit
outside you want to sit in a patio sit
in a patio you want to sit in a booth
sit in a booth
you want to sit on your thumb sit on
your thumb i'm not the world's keeper he
says he's received visits from the
health department
alcohol and beverage control and angry
citizens over the past several months
and face threats of
fines for his patio not being kohut
compliant but he remains committed to
staying open
and was emboldened by sheriff bianco's
public statements
to put himself out there for the
scrutiny has definitely
i think transcended the strength needed
for business
people in all kinds of different
capacities right now
to say hey listen my sheriff has my back
but california is reaching record levels
of covet infections
and a new more easily transmissible
strain has appeared in the state
and in several california counties
hospitals are completely out of icu
capacity
what do you say to people who look at
that situation and argue
you're creating a more dangerous
situation by failing to discourage
the spread of cobid making someone wear
a mask
or close their business that has
absolutely nothing to do with
someone that is overweight diabetic
unhealthy heart wise uh possibly cancer
going through treatments with a weak
immune system
them going out into public and putting
themselves at risk that wasn't my
fault it had nothing to do with me had
nothing to do with any other sheriff in
the state
but no one wants to take personal
responsibility
it's better if you blame someone else
there's little evidence that in-person
dining particularly outdoors is a major
source of
covid's spread a fact the state's health
director appeared to admit on a recent
zoom call the decision to include among
other sectors outdoor dining really
has to do with the goal of trying to
keep people at home
not a comment on the relative safety of
outdoor dining
research out of new york city found that
74 percent of covid spread happens in
households
rose who once worked as an emergency
room nurse says that the responsibility
for stopping the spread of kovid to the
vulnerable
doesn't rest with law enforcement or
business owners
every individual has to keep and
maintain
the amount of risk they're willing to
assume and that's inherent to the
individual
california's stay-at-home order
prohibiting restaurants in counties with
available icu capacity below 15 percent
remains in effect a judge in san diego
county ruled that restaurants there can
remain
open pending a ruling in an ongoing
lawsuit and san bernardino county has
filed suit against the governor in the
state's supreme court to keep
its businesses open rose says he hopes
more restaurants continue to ignore the
order and reopen
i'm not worried about my business as
much as i'm worried about my country
if i have nothing to open back up to
what's the point again
freedom first our choices are first your
choices are first
and i hope more and more people get on
that kind of a bandwagon to protect each
other's
rights we have to we have to do
something